if you added up the number the amount of
time that you and I spent when we were
young in rooms together being complete
asses in making each other laugh it
would it would amount to like weeks and
weeks and weeks of solid time and it was
all pure idiocy pure foolishness those
are very happy memories for me
so it's been very satisfying for me to
have see you have not only this really
amazing comedy career but tonight it's
the better call Saul fifth season finale
next season is going to be a full season
that that brings us to the you know the
real end yeah is actually in a weird way
the beginning because it's the beginning
of your character and the story of
Breaking Bad
I think they'll also tell the story of
how this guy puts his life back together
after he's gone into hiding after
Breaking Bad I think yeah but I don't
you know III never know what to believe
from Vince Gilligan and Peter Gould the
writers who lead this show when they
oftentimes say they had no plan in place
you know they often in interviews say I
had no idea what this would mean or who
who this character would turn out to be
I think they're just hard to believe
that they don't have an inkling of where
all this goes because there's no way and
it's like a Swiss watch the way they put
this together so watch Jimmy McGill over
these past number of seasons slowly
start to morph into Saul yeah you know
it was it's been an amazing fun journey
to discover this character Saul Goodman
Jimmy McGill and and I like the guy as
Jimmy I don't like a mess all yeah it's
still fun to watch him be this clown and
get into all kinds of trouble because of
it
but the real mystery of the show now is
Kim Wexler played by Ray Sehorn she's
hard to and and when people see this
final episode of season five which I
watched yesterday boy it ends completely
on her and the question of
she really is inside I think we all have
different personas we are at work and at
home and then with our significant
others and then even alone now I'm
always the same oh Jesus your poor wife
[Laughter]
really in bed guys
and I always doing takes like huh and
it's like all the time all the time yeah
so I don't know what you're talking
about and somehow and somehow you have
two kids yeah yeah they don't look
anything like me I ran into vince
gilligan recently I went to this is long
before the coronavirus went back when we
went to plays and my wife and I went to
a play and Vince was sitting in front of
us just being a real jerk making a lot
of noise yeah that's him it's one of the
sweetest genteel people I've ever met I
was talking to him a little bit and then
he said something really interesting he
said that he thinks if you as a method
actor do you think that's true I guess
Vince is probably talking about the fact
that I'm very willing you know there's a
scene in a dumpster in the first season
you know this episode episode 8 of this
season which Vince directed and it's a
masterpiece and Conan if you only watch
one episode from season five watch
season watch episode five oh eight it's
really amazing and but like I'm crawling
in the in the sand and basically I'm
gonna say let me crawl every time it's
okay as long as I'm not bleeding too
much I this is what the characters going
through so it only helps me to actually
do it it says I drew a line at drinking
my own pee yeah I didn't think I needed
to do that to pretend that I drank my
pee and help or maybe in my past I've
drank a lot of pee and I just don't
you channeled that time well in acting
class the first thing you do is drink
your own pee and got to do it so just so
you're able to play that scene one day
in Hamlet you know the hamlet and hamlet
where they drink Pete
[Laughter]